now i want to talk about this article
that i saw in the guardian
uh it's about the oxford dictionary yeah
it just got updated
um for its definition of the word woman
apparently until now its synonyms
included wench
and frail among others plus one of its
sentences
that used as an example was i told you
to be home when i get home little woman
i've never wanted to physically fight a
book but
hi so thankfully 28 year old
communications expert named maria
beatrice
giovannarti started a change.org
petition to have it updated and it went
viral leading to the alteration
now i gotta tell you
as a lover of this dictionary i'm so
glad that people are out there doing
petitions about dictionaries this gets
me so hot
thank you thank you on behalf of women
and the dictionary thank you i still
love all these little square pages of
imagination
okay i love how they feel i especially
love how they smell
oh speaking of i can now
smell like a book all the time thanks to
a new perfume
from indie bookstore powell's books
i actually was lucky enough to get to do
a reading of the book i wrote called
wildflower there
the sight scary mommy reports that the
limited edition unisex scent
is described as invoking a labyrinth of
books secret libraries and ancient
scrolls and
cognac swilled by philosopher kings
well i want to smell like that yes i'd
swipe right on that tinder profile
hot for books that's right well
okay now i'm so excited
to introduce someone who i am a huge
fan of okay her name is lucy
sparrow so please welcome her live from
her banana room
lucy are you there hi
drew it's lovely to be on the show how
are you gosh lucy i'm such a big fan of
yours i can't believe that i'm actually
talking to you
now lucy um is a felt artist
um who has exhibits in places like 30
rock you build
complete bodegas and grocery stores
and markets out of felt and i just want
to ask
how did you start doing what you do
because it's so
incredible well i mean
i started off how every artist starts
off and it's by keeping this
child-like view of the world i started
making art when i was
six or seven and i just kept making kept
working
hard and i had my breakthrough show um
in 2014 where i made a corner shop in
london
and it went viral i mean i have seen
your products and collected some of them
they are the most beautiful
whimsical you make fish you make
boxes of like products you make
groceries
and hot sauces everything
it's unbelievable when you walk in your
world it's like being in a parallel
universe of
joy and i just can't thank you enough
for coming on the show because i've been
a huge fan
for a really long time and when they
said that you were coming on i was like
she
is oh my gosh
well it's really wonderful to be here
and it's
you know delightful that i can be here
from the banana room it's like
you know i know oh by the way lucy hello
how you doing lucy i'm a big fan of
yours
and you can go to our website at the
drewberrymore show.com
and by the way it's really soft wow okay
i was not expecting that
um you can peek inside lucy's magical
world
on instagram and our website lucy i'm
very honored
that you would come on this program
thank you so much for being here i love
you thank you